bonjour et merci de nous recevoir dans
votre maison
et puis dans l' aventure aussi de votre
vie c'est un plaisir c'est un plaisir de
vous recevoir avec votre équipe
on va échanger ensemble sur le parcours
de votre vie qui est une vie assez
tumultueuse assez riche en
rebondissements je crois que
effectivement le combat fait partie
du moteur un peu de votre vie on va
peut-être faire un peu le fil de votre
histoire pour comprendre un peu ce qui a
créé chez vous cette envie de combattre
cette envie de deux d'avoir leur fut
toujours comme étant un mode de vie et
je crois que il ya une notion forte chez
vous qui est celle déjà de la
désobéissance
j'ai retenu une phrase forte c'était
méfiez-vous de l'obéissance
oui j'ai dit ça c'est vrai parce que
l'obéissance chat mène à tout et les
allemands se sont retrouvés confrontés à
l'obéissance
il ya eu les camps de concentration il y
avait beaucoup sur ils ont obéi et si
vous obéissez à quoi moi je pense que en
classe il assure il faut l'obéissance
aux parents il faut obéir mais à quoi on
obéit à quoi et pourquoi il faut
réfléchir à quoi alors bien sûr dans la
famille on obéit et parce que on obéit à
ses parents mais quand on est dans la
vie publique où quand on est adulte ou
même un peu avant avant de faire quelque
chose je le fais où je le fais pas c'est
pas parce que les autres le font que
c'est bien si pas parce que les autres
le font que moi je vais faire dont il ya
toujours ce ses traits flux enfin je
réfléchis profs on ferme à lens c'est
pas cela mais quand même je compte la
désobéissance chez vous c'était aussi
une survie ça a été vite chez vous parce
que on devait ce qui s'est passé on
devait pas sortir ou je sais pas trop
quoi et j'étais ce que c'est ça j'avais
j'avais des otites et mon père avait dit
il faut que tu restes un peu au coucher
enfin dans la maison parce que bon et
puis il faisait un temps magnifique
c'était au mois de septembre
et bien sûr me dis oh là là moi je sors
je vais faire des courses on veut jouer
à les acheter chez pas trop quoi et là
je suis sorti de mon lit tu as dit
attends moi j'y vais aussi et j'y vais
aussi je suis toujours là si j'étais pas
sortie avec ma soeur labeaume le
bombardement de 16 septembre 43 est
tombé sur la maison la moitié de notre
maison l'appartement était très grand la
moitié de la vision a été démolie et
toutes les personnes du travail qui
s'étaient réfugiés dans le porche de
chez nous sont morts et si j'aurais su
j'aurais fine qui faisait la crise chez
nous est morte avec sa nièce de 20 ans a
été tué chez nous dans notre troisième
état et si j'ai serré c'est à molitg
rapporte aussi
or j'ai désobéi à mon père en disant aux
breuleux effet tellement bon robot je
sors balade on verra ça au trophée voilà
et qu'est-ce que ça révélé en vous cette
ce moment tragique sur cette notion d
désobéissance est ce que vous avez à
disposition ces finales n'ont reçu on
dit aux enfants qui sont des hobbies
sans excès pas bien finalement la
désobéissance est de la valeur sa départ
défend désobéir accord mais quelquefois
c'est très important désobéi
ou bien vous vous acceptez et vous
torturer c'est ce qui s'est passé en
algérie pour nous les français valeureux
soldats qui étaient des garçons de 17 18
19 ans ou 20 ans qui sortent du fond de
la campagne issue qui arrive en algérie
et tout leur corps aux îles de passer
l'électricité sur un brave type qui est
algérien et qui le rôle qui leur a rien
fait qu'ils n'ont jamais vus et ils
acceptent et ça ça a été effectivement
on tourne un peu les pages de votre
histoire mais mais c'est très
intéressant c'est aussi lié à votre mari
qui était colonel et qui s'est aussi
insurgée dire que quand il vous a
rencontré vous étiez totalement en phase
sur sur votre notion de rébellion on va
dire
et je crois de mémoire que votre mari a
été le militaire le plus décoré de la
seconde guerre mondiale c'est cela et
pour autant il avait il ya une
conscience très fortes comme vous de la
justice et comment ça s'est passé en
algérie racontez moi un petit peu on
espère on va faire une petite parenthèse
sur sur votre mari et notamment sur
l'action qui l'a fait en algérie
officiellement la france faisait la
pacification en algérie alors la
pacification 56 à rendre aux gens du
coin
la possibilité de faire des courses
l'invité chez eux d'élever leurs enfants
d'avoir un jardin d'aller voir les
voisins d'avoir des magasins ouverts
vous faire des courses et éventuellement
de partir voir la grand-mère beaucoup
plus loin voilà or en réalité ce n'était
pas du tout comme ça et donc quand on
marie est arrivée en algérie pour faire
la pacification
beaucoup ont fait la pacification c'est
à dire faire la guerre contre et n'est
donc on contre le fln léman marine est
parti en algérie lui puisque
officiellement la france faisait la
pacification il a dit moi je fais la
pacification et je me souviens très bien
qu'il ya un grand général d'euro jeunes
souvent souillés pile sur nos os et donc
si très bien et qui a dit mais enfin
général c'est pas d'ordre c'est pas
digne de vous serez vous faites parce
que étant donné qu'il avait fait toute
la guerre de 39 45
donc c'était un grand combattant et bien
suivant d'algérie faut qu'ils combattent
et bon mari a répondu mais moi je fais
obéit au gouvernement on se fait la
pacification
il n'a pas eu du tout combat bld et
parce que le fln est d'accord aussi
et s'il faisait la guerre aux français
c'est parce que les français les embêter
détruisez leur maison brûler leurs
champs et au fait des choses comme ça
mais dans la mesure où les français
respectent les algériens la troupe de
mon mari a pas protégés pour empêcher
d'autres effets lettre de venir mais
cette conviction lui a valu des deux
gros problème est effectivement parce
que
le gouvernement officiellement faisait
de la pacification mais en fait tu
attendais qui face à la guerre or lui
donc la guerre il avait fait 39 45 il
l'a fait aussi bien
il a commencé en norvège il était là il
était il était qu'est-ce qu'il était
dans la légion étrangère
il était lieutenant à capitaine la
légion étrangère donc du côté de chaque
marocain
et puis j'ai retrouvé tout un cours
d'eau revêche qu'est ce qui nous a valu
aujourd'hui vous voyez avec du recul
qu'est ce qui vous a valu d'encre est en
tout cas de vous nourrir de ses
revendications et de ces injustices
forte puisque la période d'algérie c'est
une période très très forte
le fait que votre mari général à
l'époque a été pendant trois mamies ont
mis aux arrêts en forteresse en ferait
en forteresse pendant trois mois et qui
a été grâce à gaston defferre
effectivement on veut dire accompagner
dans la ville est prête
il n'empêche que ce qu'il a vécu lui
vous l'avez aussi vécu en parallèle avec
des convictions un peu similaire comment
vous comment vous apporter des choses
comment vous le vivier ça j'ai été dans
la provision à la libé suivi de
reconnaître enfin comme il faut j'ai
bien j'aime bien la nouveauté et l'a
prévu la prévu c'est intéressant
méfiez-vous de bellissen je veux revenir
un petit peu sur cette réflexion là
parce que elle a été très vrai aussi ici
sur le territoire notamment
voilà l'exemple que vous pas me parler
on va en discuter c'est sûr quimperlé
donc petite commune de bretagne sur
laquelle il ya une ligne ferroviaire qui
ne fait plus son office
les hétéros wierre paris cap et voilà et
le train il y avait des trains qui
s'arrêtent et plus donc moi je faisais
partie d'un groupe de l'association
familiale associations familiales en
principe si pour aider les ans des
femmes y avoir une aide ménagère
quand elles reviennent de maternité
enfin des trucs comme ça
et en tant qu association familiale va
je pensais que
événement qui touche les gens voient ça
me concernait aussi les train s'arrêtait
plus il y avait un train qui s'arrêtait
plus je crois que c'était le dimanche à
midi 11h55 ce train là la direction de
snc avait supprimé par oui mais attendez
des gens qui habitent quimperlé et qui
prennent le tram idier 5.3 je sais plus
si toujours des noms des chiffres ils
sont dits durables à la sncf 6 - 3 - 4 -
2 s'est jamais dette
bon alors ed prennent le train à
quimperlé pour aller à paris parce qu'à
paris près de leur boulot ou le dimanche
ou le lundi matin ils sont sur place
voilà donc c'était important d'avoir ce
train là mais non mais là est celle ci à
peu le supprimer alors nous on sait bien
l'arrêter avec l'association familiale
on s'est mis à arrêter le train bon
alors je perds fait d'ici et à 11h30
j'avais arrêté le train je met sur les
rails je préviens le chef de gare donc
on arrêter le train à trois ou quatre de
l'association une fois angers aurait été
le train à deux puisque un chien il
trace s'arrêter quand même parce que
ensuite sur les rails sans s'arrêter
mais je n'ai jamais arrêté un défi liban
moi j'ai arrêté pour avoir le temps pour
mener certaines personnes qui était sur
le quai en jetant s'arrête je monte ou h
30 soirée de jeux des sceaux voilà donc
c'est arrivé sur plusieurs fois que les
genres du train un homme et sa soeur est
à quimperlé ça m'arrange parce que j'ai
pas envie d'aller jusqu'à faire à bombes
alliées sont sinon donc pour bien situer
les choses pour que les gens comprennent
bien
vous étiez au milieu des rails oui le
train s'est arrêté
oui à 15 mètres devant vous mais un tgv
savez on est d'accord mais quand même il
était devant vous et ça a duré combien
de temps pendant deux ans ça dure
pendant deux ans vous avez tous le dit
moi je compte je fais 50 de dimanche et
comme j'avais un copain curé qui va
dépasser ventes et une bonne partie
content parce que j'ai fait surpendre de
dimanche 52 arrêts à 11h55 - 3 donc je
partais dit fier quand je vais mener ici
j'avais fini et des jeux des vaisseaux
période je suis patient apprécié à
rennes pour avoir été le tra et donc
j'ai expliqué pourquoi je le sujet et
que voilà les livres que j'avais
l'intention de continuer ah bon alors
ils ont dit qu'ils allaient mettre en
prison
alors j'ai dit écoutez
ce sera sûrement très très dur pour moi
sûrement je vais beaucoup pleurer ça
c'est certain mais par contre quand j'en
sortirai alors là vous entendrez parler
des prisons pour femmes
et là je suis pas allé en prison et je
suis pas et j'ai pas eu de demande parce
qu'il ya eu biterrois a été élu année si
je suis à messieurs c'était le bon
moment
abbas était le bon moment alors vous
avez vous n'arrêtez pas on va pas faire
la liste parce que ça va durer des
heures jacques le goff par exemple
peut-être que les gens aujourd'hui ne se
rappelle plus trop mais plogoff ça a été
une forme puisqu'il y avait une
implantation une volonté d'implanter une
autre indiqué à mme centrales nucléaires
et ça ne s'est jamais fait non ce que
effectivement j'ai vu des robots
négation et puis vous avez vous avez
aussi beaucoup oeuvré contre l'injustice
vis-à-vis de de l'armée donc vous étiez
présent pour accompagner les objecteurs
de conscience
donc c'était très très fort pour vous
puisque vous étiez représentante au
niveau des tribunaux étaient présentes
par rapport aux tribunaux et notamment
il ya eu des époques des moments très
difficiles parce que je crois que
l'armée évidemment n'acceptez pas mais
vous étiez quand même là debout face à
oui oui oui et vous aviez la de
l'énergie pour ça oui parce que je
défends des objecteurs de conscience
c'était très difficile d'être objecteurs
de conscience parce que votre père lui
il a fait la guerre de 14-18 39-45 et
donc lui il a compris société et vous
objecter on vous refuse et rentrer dans
l'armée
donc déjà dans sa propre famille c'est
difficile et objecteurs or lui refuse
d'apprendre à tuer donc les objecteurs
de conscience était condamné à deux ans
de pat forteresse de donc on les
envoyait à l'eau nf un endroit où il
était très isolé et il pouvait pas faire
de réclames pour les objecteurs de
conscience
c'est ça les avants est passé en tribu
da et donc avant il me demandait d'aller
parler pour eux et qu'est ce qui fait
que vous êtes que vous étiez que vous
êtes toujours une incessante révolter
pourquoi je ne sais pas je sais pas si
je suis révolté tout autant je suis pas
révolté par tous révoltés oui pour
certains la d61 justice est
insupportable
la géci c'est insupportable je pense
c'est notre père notre père est mort
si donc on n'a pas eu peur on a été
levée par notre père notre père était
chirurgien qui a fait 14 18 il se
souvenait d'un chirurgie il n'a pas fait
beaucoup de progrès et à transiger
tendait encore avec le chloroforme et
tout ça et il pensait voir les blessés
il disait s'il avoue blanc voyez sur la
mauvaise voie
et puis beaucoup d'autres il est laissé
il allait mourir ils savaient qu'ils
allaient mourir mais lui savait qu'il
pouvait rien pour eux cité les ventres
les ventres ans opéré un ventre si vous
n'avez pas d'antibiotiques
vous avez beau père et enlever la partie
qui est arrivé il va mourir d'affection
106 sur surtout mon niveau
donc pour mon père mon père était pour
la justice mme on a eu la chance mon
frère ma soeur est morte d'avoir été
levée par un homme juste la terre était
chirurgien c'était un homme juste
est ce que vous étiez consciente de les
éventuels risques que vous preniez dans
les différentes actions que ce soit
objecteurs de conscience que soit
plogoff que ce soit en indochine que ce
soit est ce que vous étiez consciente de
du danger dans laquelle vous étiez non
danger était points importants il dira
danger de quoi j'ai fait ça parce que je
veux dit convaincu et que je trouvais
que c'était pour la justice et pour la
vérité est bon ben voila vous étiez de
tous les combats oui tous les coups bas
j'ai beaucoup de plaisir sur il rejette
vous aviez un téléphone qui sonnait vous
disais oui c'est ça ceci le vivre moi g
-b parce que temps après avoir vécu en
indochine et en afrique noire
quand je suis arrivé ici où elle aussi
que je m'occupe et c'est ce qui fait
objet de faire c'est de s'intéresser ce
que je mets des gist rideau jaune ou
est-ce que je vais des rideaux rouges ça
me dérange pas du tout mais pour lui
tout il a bien fallu que je vivais à
m'intéresser aux choses normales de la
vie on n'est pas toujours dans les
ordinaires quand aujourd'hui on se dit
voilà vous avez un une aventure très
riche très dense très très diverse très
variés vos aventures que ce soit dans
les pays que ce soit dans l'est dans les
combats si vous aviez
en tout cas une réflexion a porté quelle
serait-elle
ainsi de se faire une idée juste des
événements auxquels on est mélangé pour
savoir où on va se situer dans ses
danses et ses vêtements là où on est
avec ont des comptes où on est neutres
si trois positions
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait par rapport à ce
qui se passe par rapport à madame untel
ou abattus alors faut s'informer un peu
de savoir qu'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement et vous pouvez participer à
le défendre
si vous pensez que sa cause est juste en
tout cas c'est un grand plaisir pour
nous de feuilleter avec vous votre livre
de votre visite histoire puis je crois
que c'est plein d'enseignements pour
nous tous parce que agir avec des
dangers avec une vraie conviction qui a
été porteuse sur laquelle vous avez
effectivement faire rayonner plein de
choses a été certainement très utile et
très constructif pour plein de gens je
vais retenir encore que ce que vous avez
dit autrefois c'est toujours c'est
méfiez-vous de l'obéissance mais merci
[Musique]